là on a une personne qui a travaillé
pour différentes boîtes de production de
téléralité vous avez travaillé merci
d'être avec nous on va vous appeler max
merci d'être là ce soir
bonjour vous avez travaillé sur beaucoup
d'émissions notamment sur les anges
alors vous travaillez encore sur la télé
réalité ou pas vous avez été témoin
d'actes de harcèlement ou d'acharnement
donc voilà c'est un petit peu sérieuse
puisque et rejoint ce qu'on s'est dit en
en prenant les deux les deux témoignages
un conte a eu avant-hier here
quelle est la position de la production
vis-à-vis de sa de l'acharnement pour
pas que ça se transforme en harcèlement
séquence souris lucidement but lâche
d'accord ça se passe comment quand les
caméras sont éteintes
est ce qu'il ya des gros clash jusqu'à
des bagarres est ce qu'il ya des choses
qu'on a qui ont été dévoilées ici par
les trois jeunes filles sont nues doit
en offre avant-hier qui m'en doute sur
plusieurs jours tous les sens alors vous
avez participé à la bataille des couples
avec notamment raphaël qui est devenu un
très bon ami à vous avec lui oui et non
ça c'est ma tin horse pas mais vous
parce qu'il ya max et maxime donc ces
exhibitions ils sont cons voilà et mais
vous vous connaissez vous avez travaillé
donc avec avec avec raphaël ou pas
moi j'ai loupé différents tournages oui
comment ça se passait avec lui a fallu
quelqu'un qui pointent pas là c'est vrai
c'est quelqu'un qui a un fort
tempérament qui peut avoir des accès de
colère il peut arriver que certaines
fois en effet ils sont elles ne va ainsi
participer ou d'accords dont vous allez
venez d vous avez vous voilà des des
comportements c'est quoi un virulent
c'est quoi virulence et sari violoncelle
dans ses propos dans ses gestes
c'est à dire que plusieurs fois il n'a
pu s'approcher du candidat sa simulation
c'est alors d'envoi lassana team est la
suivante imitation du fait des gestes
violence intimidation par les paroles
d'accord problème c'est qu'on n'est pas
hors caméra c'est qu'alors vous avez
pris la voix de maxime et arrêté sept
merci alors oui en fait il ya des
productions je me suis senti beaucoup
plus protégés hors caméra mais dans les
anges étaient clairement en insécurité
et je suis sûr que après je sais pas des
fois là prête ça doit tomber des fois
c'est pas tout le temps comme ça mais
moi ce que j'ai vécu c'était vraiment
une angoisse terrible ne pas être
protégée hors caméra j'avais peur gravel
qu'est venue la dernière fois chez vous
elle m'a sauvé une fois hors caméra la
nounou elle dormait depuis on peut
régler le problème de son valentin
stocker origines merci à zéro alors oui
et donc israël elle m'a sauvé hors
caméra il ya un candidat qui devait
d'ailleurs même peut être dans la maison
qui était qui avait fait son départ eh
ben ils étaient là ce sera il m'a sauté
dessus comme un homme le mec qui fait
fait un mètre 90 j'ai cru qu'ils
allaient m'éclater la grêle c ra one qui
m'a défendu si elle est passée à la
production ils font rien sans rien faire
et elisa s'en était même plus à la base
dans la maison alors c'est pas normal
oui ça c'est pas normal et fraîchement
bémol à tf1 il ya eu plein débordements
et on a géré effectivement l'alcool
parce qu'au début c'était un peu open
bar sur le loft après la fédérale 2
effectivement donné un
par pas candidat mais à chaque fois
qu'il ya eu le moins débordements en
deux secondes
il y avait des mois je vous dis même ce
que vous racontez là où lyon vainqueurs
étaient les moeurs l'avait repart
candidats ils peuvent pas rester deux
mois sans boire arrêté avec moi quand
les caméras et n'importe quoi excusez
moi benjamin moi je moi je vous dise
quitté la rai même quand on vit les mecs
quand on dit quand j'entends des
arguments oui ils sont jeunes ils
doivent se droguer mais on est où là ici
c'est ça les mecs vous êtes fou quoi et
c'est pas la prod qui fournit non mais
tous mine de rien vous savez ce qui se
passe ouais on arrivé là bas
et vous arrêtez s'il vous dit les mecs
qu'on a si les candidats le savent la
prod le c'est donc moi dans mon cas moi
je vous jure que c'est vrai success
story à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
problèmes d'alcool et de drogue je vous
jure que c'est vrai parce que autour du
puits les enfoncer parfois je voulais
que chaque fois c'était totalement
totalement géré totalement à chaque fois
vraiment on peut les fonds sont les
encombrements calais une caméra et scoop
ils se rejoignent tous en bas il boit de
la vodka moi je prends une douche je
vais me coucher marie ginette et ce
témoignage extraterrestre mêmes
couchettes ou alors pas posé la question
on va poser la question la témoin qui
pour l'instant
vous avez vu d'ici on a ce qu'on a pu
voir à ce qu'on a pu ressentir toussaint
ici alors juste et ce qu'il ya de la
drogue au sein du programme des anges
voilà donc il y en à la drogue quoi on a
alors parce que y'a raphaël qui nous
apparaît cannabis et il ya angèle qui
nous a parlé de coco caïd saisi une
chance si vous êtes vous étiez au
courant vous vous étiez un produit vous
étiez au courant aussi qu'il y avait de
la drogue dea des drogues dures
notamment dans ses émissions
vous étiez vous donc vous faisait partie
de la production et vous saviez que la
production était au courant qu'il y
avait des drogues dures dans ses pensées
dans cette émission
circulez nicolas ce qui est en train de
devenir et un est un véritable scandale
puisque vous savez bien que c'est filmé
donc c'est à dire que tout le monde est
complice de ce qui se passe sur ses
plateaux vous savez bien que même un
verre inverse aujourd'hui d'alcool est
interdite sur ce plateau
donc c'est interdit partout donc je suis
effaré d'entendre ce qu'a dit hier
raphaël en disant oui à peut-être un
verre de temps non non mais elle ça
n'est pas la mère si elle a dit la
vérité et pas par magie il paraît qu'il
voit pas et qui ne savent pas mais qu'il
ait dit hier naturellement qu'il y avait
effectivement des verts qui peut les
belgique est aujourd'hui mais c'est un
géant bleu ce programme est là elle a
t-on par y larguent voilà on parle de
drogue
je veux dire il ya quand même des
producteurs derrière il ya quand même
des images ya quand même des changements
le comportement il ya comme un public
derrière derrière ce genre de programme
et vous mêlez-vous twitté mag mélenchon
mais quand je vois sur twitter qu'on a
l'air étonné de ce qui se passe sur les
plateaux je vais vous dire un truc
oui je suis étonné oui je suis
scandalisé oui tu la prends aujourd'hui
ce que j'ai vu sur twitter des gens ce
qui se passe comme on en a eu il a une
autre candidate ya quelques années qui
nous l'avait dit mais oui on tombe des
nues ça veut dire que les mecs qui vont
nous dire bah oui mine de rien vous nous
dites que dans une émission
voilà qu énormément regarder de
l'ecstasy ou la cocaïne valérie non mais
moi je trouve ça absolument absolument
dingue est évidemment que je crois ce
monsieur qui nous parle là qui nous dit
que la chose n'est pas celle qui fournit
bien évidemment mais celles qui ferment
les yeux haussier moi je trouve que une
production qui fait les yeux est tout
aussi responsable pardon mais
normalement on n'a pas à fermer les yeux
puisque moi je ne sais pas si il ya des
gens de la production qui reste h24 dans
ces maisons mais moi je pense que
normalement elle devrait rester y
compris la nuit mais on doit saluer
malheur si elles ont pris la nuit tout
le temps on devrait ce qu'il ya dans les
valises on devrait et peu importe
qu'elle soit majeure ou pas majeur ça
devrait être une charte de bonne
conduite
on devrait vérifier on devrait ouvrir
les vannes libre et on devrait les
bretons ont dit ça pourquoi on dit ça 1
déjà l'exemple et est déplorable mais
deux ça change des comportements c'est
bien sûr je suis désolé moi quand vous
dites est un verre d'alcool par personne
qu'il ya là plein gré qu'est ce que vous
savez quand vous avez qui en a pas un
qui me rembarre 4 et qui va être
complètement non moi je m'appelle
prennent pas exactement c'est ça elle
boit pas il prenne son verre voilà que
je le sais vous croyez que ça se passe
comme ça je le sais très bien et après
ils ont des comportements violents
et puis on sait très bien que
la drogue et surtout des drogues comme
ça gilles ça change les comportements
totalement et ces mêmes encouragées à
partir du moment où une production même
ciel n'introduit pas la drogue ou
l'alcool
si elle sait qu'elle n'agit pas elle
cautionne est légitime elle encourage
mais si benjamin vous le savez très bien
la production pour défendre sa jeune oui
je te comprends pas je défends pas je ne
défends pas je vous lis qu'il ya une
production avec des gens responsables
il ya des gens autour qui bossent
peut-être qu'à des débordements oui il y
en a servi par l'enseigné ça fait 20 ans
qu'on sait que tous savaient pas où tu
veux dire dénonce erin arrêter sinon
vous jouez
je suis incroyablement moi je suis
choquée qu'ils aient de la drogue sur
les programmes je trouve ça ça me change
et du vin en verre orange par contre
mais oui le système qui veut ça les gens
et qu'on ne pas prendre de la drogue sur
les gens se rendent compte qu'ils ont
l'habitude de prendre
cherchons minutes voilà que ce soit je
sais pas pour vous mais je marche sur la
tête l'ong a dit bah ouais mais ils ont
l'habitude c'est fx sursis crête
il est organisé à des nouveaux arrêts
effitic ssii annonce un candidat si
c'est difficile battus et fx haute il
est engagé tout le monde sait tout le
monde sait que bin qui a dicté et ban
d'rôle trompe pas c'est un morceau et
parce que dans lesquelles s'étaient
arrêtés pouvaient pas légitime et que
des gens prennent de la drogue
je vous décris rompre un peu peur
souviens pas ma main mais là mais la
drogue de la drogue de la favela vite